TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan
for "The Developer Show."
This is your update on
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
And of course, last
week was Google I/O.
"The Developer Show"
team was on-site,
broadcasting live from all
over Shoreline Amphitheater.
Check out the playlist for
keynote recaps, exclusive guest
interviews, and play time in
the interactive sandboxes.
If you weren't able
to make it to I/O,
this is the next best thing.
The link is g.co/io/guide and
is in the description below.
Most of the sessions
were recorded as well,
and are available
at g.co/io/videos.
Now for some of
the announcements.
With ML Kit for
Firebase, you can
use machine learning to build
compelling features on Android
and iOS, regardless of your
machine learning expertise.
It's production ready
for common use cases
like text recognition
and barcode scanning,
allows you to deploy
your own custom models,
and it integrates with
other Firebase products.
It's now available in beta.
Take a look at the post for
screenshots and to get started.
Android Studio 3.2 is
available in the Canary channel
and includes features that
support the Android P developer
preview, the new Android
app bundle, and the Android
Jetpack.
Extensive screenshots and
details are on the post.
Android Things is
Google's managed OS
that enables you to build
and maintain Internet
of Things' devices at scale.
Version 1.0 is now available
with long-term support
for production devices.
The update also
comes with support
for new system on
modules, secure software
updates, and a new
console interface
to configure
hardware peripherals.
Resources are linked
from the post.
Developer preview 2
of Wear OS by Google
is now available with
support for Actions
on Google and
power-related enhancements,
including a new
battery saver mode.
The Actions on Google team
is making it even easier
for you to get started
with the Google Assistant,
drive engagement, and create
rich immersive experiences.
Recent updates include the
ability to extend your Android
app to the Assistant in more
ways, seamless digital content
subscriptions from Google Play,
and fully customizable visuals
for display surfaces.
Check out the post
for much more detail.
The new Google Photos
partner program
gives you the tools and APIs
to build photo and video
experiences in your products
that are smarter, faster,
and more helpful.
More details and a link
to the developer preview
are on the post.
Flutter is our mobile
app SDK for creating
high-quality native user
experiences on iOS and Android.
The third beta release
is now available,
with new features that
complete core scenarios.
Check out the post for
details on customer adoption,
roadmap to release, and
links to get started.
As usual, there were
a bunch of What's
New sessions and
posts from Google I/O.
Here's a quick roundup.
What's new in Android
covers all the updates
across development,
distribution, and engagement.
What's new in
Google Play Console
includes details on Android
app bundle, dynamic delivery,
and improvements to help you
understand and fix quality
issues in your app or game.
What's new in Android P beta
covers adaptive battery,
app actions, slices, and more.
The State of the Web touches on
service worker, progressive web
apps, WebAssembly,
Lighthouse, and more.
And what's new in Firebase
details ML Kit, performance
monitoring, analytics,
access management controls,
and Test Lab.
Make sure to check
out all of the posts
with the links included
in the description below.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan for
"The Developer Show."
Thanks for watching and
we'll see you next week.
Hello, I'm Timothy
Jordan for the-- yeah,
I'm going to grab some caffeine.
[LAUGHING]
I'll be right back.